Monday was not a great day because
apparently a dog bit your boob off I'm
you according to your Instagram I'm
quoting your Instagram my kids actually
did think it was all and then ask many
questions afterwards it's damaged
there's damage there's there is damage
in this area yes yes but I still love
the puppy and the puppy should find a
good home and I don't blame the puppy I
blame my boot
not that I you know I was looking at you
two taking those pictures they're not
that I wasn't exactly we were saying it
was like prob
yeah I never went to the prom so I feel
like I'm getting that out of the way
yeah that was actually I was like Seth
you look incredible beautiful no we've
been talking about it non-stop it's
highly aware I was gonna be standing
next to certain leaves for a lot of
pictures and I didn't I always have that
image in my head I have like Beyonce
next to Ed Sheeran and a t-shirt and I
was like I didn't I don't want that I
hear you I hear you okay what was it
like making this movie have you ever
dated a longshot I don't even know what
that means I don't I mean I feel like
the movie there's like a double entendre
with the title and I don't think it's
like this specific it's just the
specific mess of that we are living
we're not really living in different
worlds I think we're just we're in this
moment that we meet each other were just
have very different views the world and
he's more cynical and I've kind of
compromised and it's kind of nice I
think all relationships have an element
of that where you know the other person
makes you aware of something else I hear
you I get that you're Charlize let's
just you so you know getting here is not
good good job
oh no no no what I'm saying for the
average guy it's a long shot
it really isn't I've been single for ten
years it's not a long shot somebody just
needs to grow a pair and step up all
right you guys also besides this movie
have two pretty big things coming out
you have Adams family
you have Lion King what if Morticia
explained that to me it's so fun yeah I
mean listen I have two little ones and
they're never gonna see any of my movies
so yeah yeah he did sausage party
yes exactly and he's eva's him
incredible and so supportive and yeah
I'm just I'm really excited I mean it's
a great story and it's very timely for a
lot of metaphors of where we are in
today's place and just you know
accepting people who might not look like
us or sound like us and and so I was
happy to be a part of a story that kind
of carry something that's really funny
and really fun but also has this very
strong message behind it and how was
Lion King it's great I am thrilled to be
a part of it it was yeah it's one of my
favorite movies growing up so I tried
very hard to just not make it worse and
yeah Jon Favreau is someone I've known
for since I was a teenager so getting to
work with him again was really exciting
and yeah I very much hope people enjoy
it
do you want to hear an interesting
little yes my kids violin teacher is
playing in the symphony for a lion game
whoa there you go that's crazy yeah hey
get your kids in there yeah exactly
[Music]